oh I'm Colonel Brian over the past year
I've been taking my show around the
world I was trying to figure out where
to go next
when I got an assist from our good
friend the German comedian actor and
star a bit perfect too much like to go
to Germany maybe I could come to Germany
with you I will join you and you will
join me we would be like a three-legged
sack race but with no sack and it's not
a race we would take our
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi-oh might note you don't have to you
can come over now you're allowed since
1989 you're allowed to come over it's
okay you can be with your lover
I need something it says I am Berlin guy
what's that for this is a former East
German metal okay thank you
oh yeah thank you they train the big men
crazy big man yes that is my name in
Germany hey you think I from the
late-night show yes I am yes let a man
know
yes Letterman I'm David Letterman do you
like this so I must have this this is a
vice for sexual pleasure it's an Amish
sex toy how much is this try sick you
know for the whole dear I'd pay 30 21
like they do it yes would you want my
advice please hold my vice would you
hold my cane both stay right here
don't you try I know what you're trying
to do I'll call the police I'll call the
vice squad
hun back in America how much no it's not
the same guy is it he screwed me on the
price of a deer giving me the finger put
this is for men don't need to give you
my size or is it one size fits all yes
what size yeah whoa what are we talking
about here
stop laughing yes it's really me settle
down lose that kid's mind didn't believe
he saw David Letterman in person
you